heute morgen 7 uhr in den tafelgärten
leipzig hartz-iv-empfänger ernten hier
für die ärmsten der stadt ihr obst und
gemüse bringen sie später zur leipziger
tafel
ich finde das eigentlich unsere arbeit
ist sehr wichtig wie so oft wenn ich
wenn es nur die supermarkt alleine gehen
würden wird sich reichen die leute sagen
ja auch das ist eigentlich finanziell
nicht mehr machbar sie haben ja ihren
ihren regeln seien zu haben die idee die
die lebensmittel teurer geworden aber
die hat hier sagt wurde ja nicht
angerufen und wenn dann acht europa sind
nach euro etat vom neuen
entlastungspaket ihres finanzministers
sind sie hier mehr als enttäuscht denn
sie kommen schlicht nicht darin vor ich
habe mir vor ich doch besser ist obwohl
jetzt ja schon dort eigentlich die
pakete für die großen das ist ja noch
für die reichen eigentlich wirklich so
die inflationsrate für deutschland ist
im juli leicht gesunken und trotzdem
hoch 7,5 prozent vor allem lebensmittel
sind erneut teurer geworden im schnitt
um 14,8 prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
und das bei immer noch hohen
energiekosten inflation aktuell
35,7 prozent
berlin vergangenen mittwoch
finanzminister christian lindner tritt
vor die presse und kündigt einen
inflationsausgleich gesetz an verspricht
steuersenkungen in höhe von insgesamt 10
milliarden euro und s profitieren 48
millionen menschen davon wenn dieses
inflationsausgleichs gesetz beschlossen
er würde in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft die website von lindner
us-finanzministerium verspricht
niedrigere einkommen würden am stärksten
entlastet ein jahreseinkommen von 20.000
euro um circa 5,5 prozent ein
jahreseinkommen von 100.000 euro
lediglich um circa 1,8 klingt fair
rechnet man diese entlastung allerdings
in euro um blieben dem geringverdiener
künftig 115 euro mehr pro jahr dem
gutverdiener hingegen
479 euro
der grüne koalitionspartner wurde von
lindners vorschlag überrascht und ist
empört manche menschen können sich gar
kein essen mehr leisten aktuell und wir
müssen da helfen wo die leute gerade
extrem leiden und energie und
lebensmittelpreisen und der vorschlag
von christian lindner entlastet vier
verdiente viermal so viel wie wenig
verdienende und das untere drittel gar
nicht wer arbeitslos ist oder zu wenig
verdient um steuern zu zahlen profitiert
nicht von linden das
steuersenkungsplänen sowie die menschen
in den leipziger tafelgärten für sie
werde ja bereits auf anderem wege
gesorgt sagt der finanzminister und
formuliert es so um die menschen die
ihre bude nicht geheizt bekommen da
kümmern wir uns ja mit dem neuen
wohngeld und es gibt bürger geld für die
menschen in grundsicherung gehen die
sind eigentlich diejenigen die betroffen
sind dieser meisten brauchen ist meine
meinung und richtig genau denn die
großen die gutverdiener und
besserverdiener die kennen sich leisten
die gucken da nicht drauf oder sonstwas
der pläne darauf ihrer oder oder die
wenig verdienen die müssen wirklich
jeden cent zwei morden drin die
inflation wird die soziale frage nicht
nur für hartz iv empfänger sondern auch
für menschen wie rentner norbert altmann
die wenig haben aber nicht von
sozialleistungen leben ja und das ist
unser wohl stube und küchenbereich für
ein leben in der stadt reiche seine
rente einfach nicht aus vor sechs jahren
zog altmann deshalb in den wohnwagen auf
dem campingplatz in colbitz hier zahlt
er nur 150 euro miete
werde ich garantiert
noch weniger zu
1500 euro hat alt meine monat inklusive
witwenrente der wocheneinkauf 30 euro
teurer altmann spart beim essen wird
kaum noch auto um die preissteigerungen
aufzufangen auch sein gas ist 30 dollar
ich will nicht frieren wir müssen kochen
und ich muss mit duschen für menschen
wie norbert altmann geht es nicht darum
auf luxus zu verzichten oder sich ein
wenig einzuschränken für ihn ist die
inflation eine existenzielle frage auf
hilfe aus der politik wollte er da
lieber nicht mehr warten wenn jetzt
sowieso unsicher oder sich einfach sage
jetzt muss irgendwas machen
weiter lehnte kennen und wie sollte warm
zu haben
weiterhin investiert und das geld wie
wir dahin wo es noch keins solange wir
jetzt geht es noch ganz von seinem
beerdigungs geld hat der 65 jährige
einen kleinen ofen gekauft mit dem hofft
er über den winter zu kommen ich habe
einfach jetzt noch mal von dem ersparten
geld was eigentlich ein normaler weise
erfolgt nun mal stern sollte die stille
reserve jetzt angegriffen weil ich
gesagt aber das musste einfach mal was
was noch mal machen wir damit eine
sichere sache heißt falls wirklich gast
nicht mehr kommt oder nicht bezahlbar
ist halt man kennt den preis für sein
gas genau aber vielen mietern wird die
gasrechnung erst im kommenden jahr von
ihren vermietern präsentiert werden die
hälfte der gaskunden sind kunden die
über die nebenkostenabrechnung
die ihre heizkosten zahlen das heißt der
ein oder andere wird das erstmal
verdrängen trotz der medialen diskussion
um die steigenden gaspreise hoffen dass
das schon gut gehen wird und wird dann
erst im jahr drei 2023 sein blaues
wunder erleben auch altmanns nachbarn
finden lindners entlastungspaket sei
sozial nicht gerecht
100.000 euro hat das ehepaar teubner aus
ostfriesland in seinem mobil heim
gesteckt
die steuerentlastung die der
bundesfinanzminister für sie vorgesehen
hat würden sie ihren nachbarn können sie
und viele andere müssten derzeit noch
nicht entlastet werden es gibt genug in
der die die am einkünfte die können das
noch verschmerzen gehören dazu mehr als
um ihr geld sorgen sich toll dass um den
sozialen frieden in deutschland
und man hört immer so ein bisschen mehr
raus
also dauern kann wenn es knallt die
verteilung ist zum ungerecht die kleinen
leute haben einfach zu wenig und die
bisherigen entlastungs paket der
bundesregierung hätten daran so wenig
geändert
eigentlich zu häufig sind maßnahmen
ergriffen worden die dann doch mit der
gießkanne funktionieren oder sie sogar
den oberen einkommensgruppen mehr
genutzt haben zum beispiel den tankwart
hilfe vor allem für die ärmeren was
längst hätte passieren müssen verspricht
der kanzler nun für den herbst ich habe
das zusammengefasst mit der formulierung
der kanzler will niemanden alleine
lassen der finanzminister macht
alleingänge und während sich die
regierung nicht einig wird wächst die
zahl der menschen bei der tafel in
leipzig von tag zu tag ohne dass obst
und gemüse aus den tafelgärten während
sie hier aufgeschmissen denn es kommen
immer mehr menschen die sie versorgen
müssen eine aufgabe die die politik
ihnen stillschweigend übertragen habe
die tafeln sind ja eigentlich dazu da um
lebensmittel zu retten das ist ja die
grundaufgabe gewesen und die hat sich
entwickelt zu einer ich sage mal ich
sage mal breiten sozialen institution
die heute wirklich sozial fälle
behandelt und das ist eigentlich nicht
mehr zu diesem zweck gewesen wozu die
tafeln einmal geschaffen worden und dann
werden die leute ich sage mal mit dem
hartz iv satz aus ich sage es mal ganz
ruhig er aus fressen reduziert dann habe
ich kein verständnis mehr für solche
leute die in solchen ämtern sind
steuerentlastungen für gutverdiener auch
für rentner altmann kommen sie zur
völlig falschen zeit
europas haben das müsste darum oder so
seine magie die nix haben es geht um den
sozialen zusammenhalt in deutschland die
regierung muss schnell für einen
gerechten ausgleich sorgen